vendre ses produits directement au
consommateur voilà le mode de
fonctionnement de cette coopérative
alimentaire située à sibranda Boren en
Frise dans ce potager en permaculture on
récolte une centaine de fruits et
légumes différents que l'on peut se
procurer avec un abonnement saisonnier
en Free il y a plusieurs
ça permet que
les connais les légumes ils savent d'où
il vient et comme ça on fait
un lien entre le producteurs et les
consommateurs dans la région on recense
plus de 200 initiatives semblables liées
à l'économie circulaire
depuis la guerre en Ukraine réduire sa
consommation de gaz et devenue un devoir
stratégique pour l'Union européenne à
egg village de 2000 habitants à côté
d'un grand lac on a décidé de miser sur
l'aquatermie
travaillons sur un gros projet
prendre la chaleur du lac en été
l'enterrer profondément dans le sol
la chaleur restera là
on pourra grâce à des moyens
technologiques la déterrer pour chauffer
les maisons
on aurait plus besoin de gaz mais nous
pourrions chauffer les maisons grâce à
la chaleur de l'eau
dernière visite pour les délégations du
projet JIRA it's feta house un bâtiment
administratif d'une centrale électrique
construit avec 44% de matériaux recyclés
avec parfois des techniques inattendues
comme cette table réalisée à partir
d'anciens jeans et c'est donc une autre
façon de concevoir des buildings des
maisons des qui permettent de prendre en
charge et de prendre en considération
tous les problèmes liés à la
construction j'ai été impressionné par
une table qui est en fait une table de
comprimé de gin ancien qui a été
comprimé avec une sorte de colle
biologique et c'est assez impressionnant
pour ça les délégations du projet JIRA
se retrouveront en Allemagne du 23 au 26
février